[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to another edition of
bonehead of the week gabe how are you
i'm good how are you oh i'm i'm doing
fantastic if i could get the order down
right you know on these uh
you know i you think i'd have this down
by now by the time i uh you know do uh
like the [ __ ] list and on the podcast
but i'm still working on this the live
directing thing i'm getting yeah
yeah we'll see
i'm gonna get maybe uh maybe i will be
the bonehead of the week eventually
yes
could i be the bonehead of the week is
that a thing we could have you could
throw your you could throw yeah we could
have like a we could have like a
separate race just with your own head
and each week it could just be you or me
or
yeah okay so it's like they could vote
see if we actually work in but this week
last week last week was tucker carlson
uh and we're a little late to the game
here on bonehead of the week but we had
some technical difficulties yesterday
but we're glad to bring you bonehead of
the week now
uh because this was like a runaway this
is even more of a runaway race than
tucker carlson was right out of the gate
it was just
this one person
take a moment if you want to guess who
it is
right you can only guess who this is
right
yeah at this point you can only guess
it's done but i'm just saying before you
show what the results were this person
right from the start
they just
jumped leaps and bounds in front of the
other two
oh absolutely and it was no rate it was
no contest to the race from there on in
so so let's let's show the results here
uh of course uh chris cuomo and we'll
talk about each one of these boneheads
but chris cuomo came in just under
uh eight really just over seven percent
i should say it's 7.4
donald trump jr at 12 which really
surprises me this is um this is
something i did not see i really thought
he would perform better at bonehead of
the week here but you know with lauren
bobert it really is not much of a race
yeah
i i will say this like every week
something new happens and uh you know
and every day it's like who is
who who is gonna do the shittier thing
right
you know to to surpass this other person
and lauren beaubert she was just like
hold beer to donald trump
insane
uh because what i mean yeah it was just
yeah and then she doubled down on it
right well not only that it's like just
just the video clips after video clips
of video clips because of course she's
just
completely about all the attention no
matter good bad or indifferent she
doesn't give a [ __ ] it's just how how
many how many uh how many millions of
views can these videos get and i don't
know how many patriot takes did but
we're gonna watch several patriot takes
today yeah they had a whole it was like
watching a like an encyclopedia like
release of
content there were volumes
of videos that they had done
what's crazy is even even since the poll
closed and we were going to do the bonus
of the week yesterday we had some
technical difficulties but
the point is is that there was another
video today did you see there was
another video today that dropped where
she where she tries out this this
[ __ ] jihad squad thing um and this
was that where she was in front it was
like in a hall yeah i think it was
turning points usa no no this one's like
turning points usa this is this was back
she's been trying this this uh this this
phrase out for a while um that really
everyone started to pay attention to
right the one that she apologized to be
like i didn't mean to offend anyone but
then right in in multiple accounts
previous and probably she's been saying
right yeah absolutely she goes to bed
and she she prays that right
[Laughter]
you know and and the the fact that she
doubles down and we'll watch some of
these videos the fact that she doubles
down and she's like
ah [ __ ] you i'm not really sorry like
i'm sorry but i'm not but i don't and
then go ahead i was gonna say i don't
even think it's not even actually
doubled down because it was like she the
video gets released she does the tweet
then she makes the apology video right
and then she goes on to laura ingram
and
like she like tripled down on it
and was like i'm the victim i'm not
getting canceled and it's like whoa whoa
what what you know in this bone end of
the week thing at first we were like are
we gonna be able to get you know three
people a week and it really doesn't
matter if we have three or not because
we're gonna at least have one complete
utter [ __ ] bonehead
of the week and really the craziest part
is with this poll we put this out before
the crumblies thing happened we put this
out before the patriot front which we
might have something in store for
patriot front today um
and that you know all that all those
people could have ended up on the list
and i i don't know that lauren beaubert
still she probably still would have won
you know
yeah i mean i guarantee that uh
i mean the fact that lauren billboard
stuff is still
getting out because it's you know it's
to you know show that she wasn't either
sincere or genuine and the fact that
she's going to continue the same type of
rhetoric
you know and she's you know especially
for someone who's like i am a
i forgot what you said she's like uh
you know a a faith
a woman of faith right i think is what
she said
who can tell with this idiot oh no no i
know but i just it's that hypocrisy but
like i am a person of god and i love la
la la la and
you know i mean just my god not your god
[ __ ] your god right yeah exactly my god
is almighty
oh [ __ ] so let's let's get to the uh the
other two contestants here and let's
let's explain to the folks here why they
made it the bone of the week of course
chris cuomo um and he there was some
news on him uh going forward from this
as well because uh uh maybe you can tell
the folks here he actually he used he
used his credentials right is that what
happened here yeah yeah we would say
credentials i mean like his brother came
to him and for guidance basically advice
on how to navigate
uh
from the the new side
of things for his brother who is the you
know former governor of new york
and uh
yeah that's just not something you do
and then it wasn't until things started
to come out
you know around the
[Music]
uh around when his brother was
uh resigning
or getting called for resigned to this
did the initial reports come out and
then this other
or rather more info came out about it
after the fact and then you know the
resignation and then the termination
right because he was suspended first for
i don't know it was about 24 48 hours
and then they finally announced that he
was being fired which by the way the
poll the poll came out before the
termination happened
right actually i think we actually
released it on twitter before he was
even suspended technically
yeah um
i because i it was unclear to me rather
it was a self-suspension kind of thing
where he's like hey i'll step aside or
if if uh cnn actually said okay we're
gonna suspend you for now until we
decide what to do because i i would i
would suspect cnn wanted to see if they
could wade through this thing and it was
obvious after several days that there's
no way
um that they could wait through this and
i doubt chris cuomo for at least 12 to
18 months finds any job on tv at this
point well i mean if you look look at
tubin he came back after what seven
eight months yeah well lubin and tubin
is a little different than using your
actual news sources to try to protect
your your right your your ex-governor
brother from sexual assault allegations
i mean no i i do want to point out to
the audience that we do not we we do not
approve of anything that tubin did while
he was lubin on that zoom call okay oh
well
as long as you're doing it in private i
i totally support lubing and tubing as
long as you're doing it yeah i mean if
you're not bothering anyone and it's
your own thing behind closed doors not
right on a zoom call when you think that
you're on mute and your camera's not on
but you still figured hey we're taking a
five-minute break for water
let me just
you know well you know
you got a lube and tube sometime but the
best time to do it is not in front of a
a computer with a camera that possibly
might be on it's doing it on your own
time that's right
right at least i will say this at least
it wasn't
on
film it wasn't like on tv or something
oh right live tv like yeah like it was
like oh we're going to a commercial
break he's like oh [ __ ] i got 90 seconds
i gotta get it out gotta gotta
gotta rub one off real fast you know
okay so enough of the lumen tube and cnn
and chris cuomo stuff let's go back to
the uh contestants here because don jr
uh was also one of the guys you know
what he did yeah yeah yeah so don jr
really
really makes sure that he's able to uh
stay in that shitty person uh
um like platform that he that he has
um and basically there was a game it was
a lakers game and there was this couple
that were on the sidelines saying some
pretty terrible things about his son
dying his kids dying
and lebron went over to the ref and he
was like yo these people keep saying
this stuff really messed up which i
think i don't you know for a party that
for a party that's all about saving the
children and caring about the children
don jr goes on to
social media twitter instagram and what
have you
and talks about how lebron james is
a [ __ ] and he's a karen and yeah
for complaining
you know what's funny about this you
know what's funny about this is you
remember back when donald trump first
became president
way way back in the fashion yeah i feel
like that was 20 years ago right exactly
so we go all the way back in the first
few months when michael flynn had to
resign because he's a traitor and he's
lying about his russian contacts we have
all this turmoil because they can't get
this presidency off the ground and they
distract the entire country with the the
picture of kathy griffin you remember
the picture kathy griffin holding up the
the oh right trump mask remember this
trumps and they're like oh
this is so egregious oh you're hurting
baron and all this [ __ ] you know you
remember that
oh yeah yeah don junior same way and
then and then here is don jr calling
calling lebron james a [ __ ] or whatever
you know weakling or right you know it's
snowflake whatever the [ __ ] and i don't
uh let's see if we can find it here what
he what he actually said i i don't even
know if i have the uh
the tweet queued up because uh [ __ ] john
don jr but the the point is is that when
when the when the shoe is on the other
foot of course they act the same way as
they accuse other people of acting and
lebron james also lebron james was doing
was pointing out to the referee that hey
these [ __ ] people they can say [ __ ]
about me playing basketball or hell they
can probably throw racist racial
epithets at him and he doesn't really
give a [ __ ] right but when you talk
about his children and and that kind of
[ __ ] you know you are kind of crossing a
line because let's face it these guys
are there for entertainment but black
people are not just there to entertain
you and you can treat them however you
want and still be entertained and that's
kind of how these these few white folks
uh treated it the this this uh and she's
kind of you know i i want to use the c
word here but uh because she was walking
out as she was walking out she gives the
patty face like lebron james was being a
baby right you know i don't know she was
like like it was it was clear from their
response
that they went there
with the sole purpose of saying
just there's got to be expensive tickets
though right i mean it was floor seats
what was it was it at the staples center
well it's not the staples anymore but
was it at the staples center is that
where this happened i i don't know
i don't remember that part
um i've got the video here but i don't
want to play the video for copyright
things because it's uh i believe we'll
get dinged on copyright for playing the
thing
uh i'll just play the play the video in
twitter and then just mute the sound
and let me see if i can find the the
lebron video i don't know if i can find
the the video it was difficult to find
this video oh here here here's here's
here's the tweet uh we'll give aaron
credit here uh here's the tweet from don
jr of course it is it looks like it's in
indiana because this is the pacers oh
yeah yeah yeah right so it was in india
which is which is even more it's like oh
yeah indiana cool great all right that
makes sense
all right so here's i guess i mean those
floor seats probably aren't very
expensive then they're probably right
yeah right a couple bucks you know two
three dollars i don't know maybe maybe
maybe a little more than a coke and a
hot dog would be at the game probably
like by a 12 bucks piece but you see
here you see at the bottom here the uh
the the
the
lady the the nice polite lady here she's
a [ __ ] is what she is with with her lips
sticking out you see that and then uh
her little her little i don't know what
the hell he is but he's obviously a
pacers fan i mean he thinks it's funny
he thinks it's hilarious you know
obviously these people can just afford
uh even floor seats in indiana but can
afford to throw them away but that
donald trump says
is there a bigger [ __ ] in pro sports
than le snitch
it really is funny that don jr is
calling lebron james a [ __ ] you know
what i'd like to see you know i'd like
to see don jr call lebron james a [ __ ]
to his face i think that would be oh
yeah
i don't i don't i think if presented
with the situation like he just rolled
up and he's like hey how about you say
what you said on your instagram to my
face
and he goes because oh my god what would
you would you would you signed a would
you sign an autograph for my kids yeah
please like i guarantee he would just oh
yeah
i love you ron you're the greatest
player of all time right yeah autograph
[ __ ] he's like i've been to all your
games i watched all your games oh you
you're the best you know right right but
here's here's the tweet here's the tweet
here's the donald jump and oh and not
the tweet i guess it was on instagram
that he posted this [ __ ]
i post this [ __ ] on uh on insta on the
grammy grams um but uh let's see by the
way i just want to point out that donald
trump uh junior's instagram is is like a
toxic wasteland
of like
memes and you're over there a lot you're
over there a lot huh oh yeah well i mean
like you know i'm occasionally looking
for videos that i can just like
just make fun of for but he's like you
know
right under paul gosar for some of the
stuff that he posts on there like he's
you know he posts all the stuff about
like
let's go brandon but it's like blood and
all it's pretty intense what
donald trump jr does and at the same
time he's like are you are you telling
me he's being a little [ __ ] on
instagram while he's calling oh
100
i mean like remember with that one
remember that one time when he did the
video which by the way is where i pulled
the photo of his face
is oh for for a bonehead where he's in
bed like this you know this one here
that's that's where he's in bed
complaining about how instagram is
throttling his account and oh yeah the
algorithms the algorithms are killing me
or some [ __ ] right yeah and he's
complaining about it anyway that's where
that uh that lovely photo is from
just him doing a full like thumb face in
bed
fantastic well so uh let's get to the
the the do we want to do the
dishonorable mention first and then
we'll get to the the winner here yeah
yeah we'll do dishonorable mention okay
so so here's the dishonorable mention uh
of course is patriot front you guys
heard about this kkk nazi neo-nazi
uh fake patriot or i called it patriot
farce
um yeah
yeah my name for them is patriots now
what is it
fake tree it's is the one that i'm going
with now yeah
i get you let's see let me see if i can
get some you're a bunch i mean like at
the end of the day they're a bunch of
cosplaying wannabe in cells
that run the streets and then call their
mom for a ride right well the craziest
part to me is the the um
oh geez
it just it's the it's the
the
this is fake
well yeah it's a false flag thing like
because the neo-nazi thing is not good
for their brand right it's it's really
is bad it really is bad imagery for gqp
and republican branding and it's really
bad for all these maga trump pumping
idiots out there because they really
don't they don't like to be called nazis
they i mean they want to be nazis but
they don't like they call yeah but they
don't like the name right yeah right and
when they see this type stuff and we got
a video here now let's see this person
posted a video this has to be real from
um
from there it's not really really i mean
it's got the logo
right the guy's got the white mask it
looks like let's see what this uh
let's
let's see let's go back here i'm gonna
give it i'm intrigued reclaim america
has anyone seen the u-haul trucks i
think i left my white mask in there
never mind guys i'm just gonna use my
tighty whities my mom packed us some
checks in case you get hungry
gotta protect your identities i don't
wear masks for cobin we are white
nationalists it seems like someone
bought those brand new for this
no a bunch of teams maybe i don't know i
mean no no that was last time in philly
and that was like a mob of like
like 12 teens i just bought my khakis on
black friday at walmart it was a vogue
are coming back to pick us up they
wouldn't leave us behind right yeah
right yeah they would mom can you come
pick me up
my friends left me again yeah i have
your cookware
i don't know who this
is i don't know how this is i don't know
who made this guy get me a video
man did that seem accurate i gotta tell
you whoever made that video bravo to
them because
yeah yeah
it was almost right yeah
yeah i will send them some kudos uh
i feel like they were almost there on
the street you know
right but the thing that i find the
funniest about this is how
again like what you're saying you got
margery taylor green you've got wendy
rogers they don't like the idea of being
called neo-nazis nazis fascists whatever
and then they're just like oh this looks
like something out of a movie set you
know meanwhile you've got the leaders of
patriot front who are from
uh united who are [ __ ] neo-nazis
right who are nearly charlotte's bill
right did you know so do you know that
this is actually a break off from the
vanguard group yeah so so explain that a
bit uh because the vanguard group is the
one that actually he's the the vanguard
member is the one who was convicted of
murdering heather uh heather heyer isn't
that her name the one who got he ran her
over with the yeah i think yeah yeah i
said heather
i think that's her name
he ran her over with the car in the
crowd right
he he was a member of vanguard correct
yeah yeah and after and after that event
of in 2017 they broke off and they
created this new group which was what is
called a patriot front right and now
which is the ones we see here on the
screen right exactly and i think
back then their logo was like black and
white but now it's you know patriotic
and it's red white and blue
so so is it the same logo then and it's
just it's just
if i recall it's not the same logo i
mean they still they had shields in
charlottesville as well
um
but
i i don't believe it's the same logo
uh let me i can look it up really quick
you know you know why you're looking it
up because i'm watching the video here
and these guys are just it is almost a
parody in and of themselves number one
they have they all decided that white
masks were going to be like the uniform
like why why did you pick white you
should have done black i mean white
hoods why i mean really you're like
and then they have the flags upside down
which is america in distress
um right which
and then the banner here which they
can't get straight here because they got
you know tubby and tubby junior here
carrying it but uh it says reclaim
america and my comment was on twitter
white fragile males
reclaiming america from fragile white
males like what are you talking about
you haven't lost america jesus christ
you're just pissed that you think you
you think you're gonna you know oh my
god the majority of
of of businesses the majority of vote
the majority of politicians is now gonna
be 81 instead of 89 white i get the [ __ ]
out of here man
you you don't even make sense and then
the best part about this whole thing
because the shields are funny
but these guys have knee pad why do they
have knee pads on were they planning on
sucking uh you know doing the lube and
tubing thing or what what are the knee
pads for i'm i'm not exactly sure uh i i
sent you the link for what they used to
look like it looks like honestly
it looks uh like a bunch of people
in front i mean like at least now they
have some sort of like uniform going on
because in charlottesville
they looked like
they were
larping they had their shields it looked
like it was some sort of game they were
about to play in some field and they had
sticks and shields and this and that and
costumes and what have you
and it's just
it's so so dumb like here we go this is
what they used to look like right this
is what they used to look like this is
like i think this is more or less when
they were like still figuring it out
right so they still have the khakis they
still have the khakis on you see that
yeah yeah they love the khakis but they
had white polos and tiki torches and and
it was a black logo with the eagle on
there and then they had a second one
which is a black logo with uh what
appears to be some sort of axe or i
don't know something yeah it looks it
looks way it looks way more nazi this
stuff looks way more right yeah the
other stuff is more like americana type
they're going right right so then they
then they pivoted after 2017 and they
became known as patriot front so they
know that
if you look here if you look here let me
see if i can zoom in on this picture do
you see who this guy is back here in the
background do you see that guy you see
behind the red shield here do you know
who that yeah yeah that's the guy that's
the guy who mowed down
uh
isn't that the guy
isn't that the guy it might it might i
think that is the guy
i think that's the guy here um but you
see they have their their their like
their helmets on and
um you know for for people who that is
that is the guy james alex fields junior
and is it heather higher isn't that her
name i just want to make sure i had that
right um let me just see really quick
there's there's
so many people that were have been
needlessly killed by a bunch of [ __ ]
white fragile males
that it's hard to keep track sometimes
of
the list of folks
um but yes this is the guy that's the
guy that that in that in the uh
i think he was driving like a dodge
challenger or something um i'm not gonna
show that video but right but where he's
running through the crowd so
um
[Music]
but this is this is this is the uh this
is the the heather heather hire yeah
that's right higher is her name yeah so
i thought okay so let's let's uh let's
move on to the winner let's let's play
the video show them show them who the
winner is and then we'll talk about the
winner uh here okay let's go on to to uh
mama knots
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so congratulations to lauren pew pew
bobert
for winning bone end of the week mama
nazi since we were talking about nazis
um right because she certainly is a
white supremacist this is here's the
video from patriot takes uh gabe that
shows the
uh the newest version of the
oh well i don't know what you gonna see
what i would i'm also curious
yeah so what i'm curious about is how
many times
because we know that the story has
changed from her perspective right each
time she tells it it's a little bit
different and it's
she obviously wants to
uh seem like she's a badass right lauren
lauren wants to be like oh i stood up to
this you know non-white non-american you
know right immigrant and i called her
racist names right and i said it and i
set it to her face
but at the end of the day i want to know
like i know that the story has changed
so either it did happen and she's like
sprucing it up to make it perfect from
her perspective or it never happened and
it's what she thought in her head after
the fact when like you know when those
moments when like you're talking to
someone you're like oh that would have
been like a
a really good good comeback you know and
in this instance it's just downright
terrible
but i do wonder like if the story is
true to some extent did she ever really
say that because i know that ilhan omar
was like that never really happened she
never would ever she would never say it
to my face
so
here's the thing let's listen to this
video now i'll show i think i'll give
you my theory on what i think yeah she
doesn't show up to work
sorry she votes by proxy
a lot of members vote by proxy by the
way
very never republicans that do it too oh
[ __ ] well of course i'm in congress no i
haven't gone toe-to-toe with aoc she
doesn't show up to work
i'm trying to get there we go that's
what i want i just want to get to the
meet here because uh
here's where it is the jihad squad
that's it they come in for work
okay so so that's so so that the g hot
squad
and again this is some turning point usa
thing um so this is june she said it in
september then she said it again this
right this past month so so this midas
touch video that i have here let me let
me go to it real quick um they actually
have uh
a couple of patriot takes uh takes on
this and they have it combined so i'll
bring this video up here
see if i can get it up there we go on
his first day with me got into an
elevator this is the elevator story this
is where it starts with the elevator
yeah this is v1
right check out the break check out the
priest in the back by the way
well i mean you know and all the time
it's gotta it's gotta be godly
right
you know sanctioned sanctioned by
by jebus himself
of course he's trying to hide his face
like oh my gosh oh no no no but it's
hilarious
now here's here's the one that everyone
the first one everyone seen in the
cracker barrel as you call it
my first jihad squad moment here you go
jihad squad see
i was getting into an elevator here's
the elevator story again she's evolving
with the elevator so so i ain't gonna
play the whole thing again but she says
jihad squad she says the elevator thing
again now um
let's see if i can find
the okay so so what happened was is she
had a phone call
um
with omar
apologized to her apparently on the
phone call it was kind of a half-ass
apology apparently and then she released
an apology on her official twitter
account not her personal on her official
right
and then but the tweet happened first
she okay
the tweet happened after the like
basically after the video from patriot
takes got so much
attention
right she releases a tweet that says
you know i i apologize she never really
said i apologize i don't think she did
but i remember it being like uh
i don't mean to offend anyone with the
things that were said you know it went
over it went over like a wet fart and a
white thong it really right right it was
and then she yeah and then she did uh a
video on instagram
where she said that she called ilhan
omar after you know it was after because
this all happened during thanksgiving
like the whole holiday weekend
and then it was at the end of it where
she was like oh i finally got in touch
with her
and i tried to apologize but she wanted
me to say publicly
and she got all like hot and bothered
about it
and by the end of the video
she was the one who was claiming to be
the victim because she was saying that
she was like oh i'm here to defend
america from this and that and ilhan
omar is
uh clearly one that supports domestic
terrorists and i was like whoa or just
terrorists in general i think right well
well i mean what she's trying to say is
muslims are terrorists is what she's
right yeah that's the whole jihad squad
thing that's the whole yeah
she called them terrorists on the floor
of the house she calls she says diet
squad and and really she said it on the
floor of the house that's when everyone
noticed it and then patriot takes
unearths a video of her and quote
unquote the cracker barrel
making the the jokes because she wasn't
joking on the floor she's trying to make
jokes in front of her constituents she
was serious on the floor of the house
but i believe i believe the reason why
she put an apology on her twitter
account is because we see we have kevin
mccarthy here because uh later on the
press had asked kevin mccarthy at his
press conference why the hell
is she still on
uh committees after she's saying these
things and here's here's what this div
[ __ ] had to say
loin bird apologized publicly
i wanted her to so that way i could say
this in front of you she wanted me
personally she wanted me personally
right
denied the ability to meet personally
denied when she picked up the phone and
she called
congresswoman omar she said i want to
personally apologize
that's what she did i think in america
that's what we do and then we move on on
the issues that need to take place we're
racist we say we're sorry and then we
move on and then it's okay
and then he goes on to steve king which
uh if you remember steve king said some
racist [ __ ] which steve king has been
being racist for decades before this
yeah it just so happened
right and right it just so happened that
social media amplified him is all it did
which put kevin mccarthy in a shitty
position that he had to either defend
stephen king
or take him down off his committee
assignments
the problem the problem that kevin
mccarthy had with stephen king is
stephen king was being racist towards
black people as opposed to a religion
right which which isn't yeah you know oh
that's not you know
you can't do that but we can make we can
make uh you know
hard-handed remarks about a certain
religion and that someone's a terrorist
because of that religion um so kevin
mccarthy obviously is being uh you know
he's tr he he he forced lauren bobert to
put the apology on her official account
so that he could say this in front of
the press that's what i think
oh yeah they because i think at the end
of the day they also need to say there
was a paper trail we did right what we
needed to do
to show the american people and the
person that we offended or attacked that
we actually you know
she apologizes we're not racist we're
not i mean that's like that's
but that's also like when he had
margaret taylor green go outside after
her uh star of david holocaust
mask nancy pelosi uh comments and she
went out to apologize she's like i went
to the
holocaust museum
and i learned so much about what
happened
and then you know went on about it but
then at the end of the day she then she
comes back to those same talking points
and repeats herself later on after the
dust is settled and she's apologized
because people are you know rightfully
so really pissed off right well and that
way that way she can say she still went
to the holocaust museum even even as
many times as she says that in the
future she can say well i went to the
holocaust museum right you know i'm sure
you know i'm i'm sure if she could she
would go with madison cawthorne and go
check out the the fuhrer's home the
eagles nest or whatever
someone someone called did you see
someone called madison cawthorne on
twitter i didn't call them this and i
may or may not have retweeted this but
they called him sittler
that was
i'm i'm not condoning it i'm just
i'm sorry
you know i'm i'm not i think it's uh
anyways
i guarantee he will find his way on
bonehead of the week yeah oh madison
oh yeah even even the comments from this
past week about women being a vessel and
all the [ __ ] yeah
yeah when he's when he's talking about
abortion because he can't you know he
can't please a woman probably and he's
never had the opportunity to that's why
he's got to say the things that he's
saying about women being vessels and and
using his god as the reason to
dehumanize him which is you know
pathetic and of itself so i'm sure that
[ __ ] [ __ ] bag will make his way on to
the [ __ ] list eventually so here i want
to show this video the patriot takes
also did this pager takes did us a huge
service on the bone end of the week this
week
um
and that this is uh on um some kind of
[ __ ] right-wing nazi traitor tv thing
um that patriot takes keeps tabs on and
lauren bobert here is talking about the
the incident of the like the you know
the apology and all that but but listen
listen this is after kevin mccarthy had
said what he said um we have serious
issues with a terrorist and that is a
member of congress
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me like i i
could just play just that right there
and know exactly what's funny is is
what's funny is on screen here let me
make this bigger
on screen here she's saying a terrorist
in congress
and paul gosar
is on the screen as she's saying this
now watch what happens because i think
people in the uh in the control room
like oh [ __ ] this looks horrible this is
terrorist and it immediately pulls paul
goes our officers
she would have one of those like eat
pray love holy spirit like wine is life
things well she she had to take the guns
down behind her because yeah well this
is i don't know it's just in her home
it's in her office i i don't
well it sounds like she's in a horrible
cave she needs to figure out her
microphone situation you think someone
who is such a social media you know
uh uh
troll
would figure out a microphone situation
but you know one million dollars of
campaign funds too i think there's a
couple other maybe this is in like the
side room in the cracker barrier she
wants to call me
like a little like business center but
hey dan uh i just wanted to do it
i was like oh maybe it's like a little
business center you know yeah it could
be it could be like a like a bedroom but
anyway she's doubling down here on a
traitor tv real america whatever but she
also whether you know probably
intentionally you know doesn't say who
it is because i feel like you know as
soon as you say this person is a
terrorist right
right i'm no legal expert but i'm pretty
sure that constitutes for defamation
wow so
i mean again the especially a city
member of congress
i love that the uh the control room
pulls paul goes our what is this four
hours four hours here's another patriot
takeover boy turning points usa event
again
uh once again she's going after
uh aoc oh connor if you look here uh
alexandria castro
so you know they're they're obviously
they love their nicknames you know well
you know that's why that's why i give
them nicknames because yeah you know as
much as as much as uh people want to
scoff at it it actually does work it
gets into side people's psyche people
like it that's the let's go brandon
thing they did this they did this so
they could chant [ __ ] joe biden in
church right
right yeah
right and and they separation of church
and state though you know right right
but but the reason why they want to have
these nicknames is that way they can say
it in polite company they can say racist
[ __ ] that they wouldn't normally be able
to say
uh like the preacher in the back
laughing at jihad squad right i mean
that's that's the whole code word let's
go brandon
you know welfare queen like i'm not
totally racist you know right it's like
racism with a little bit of like with a
weird frosting on top yeah
yeah
racism with a wink yeah so so
congratulations
uh once again let's play it one more
time for lauren
[Music]
[Music]
so we haven't figured out exactly who
the bonehead of the week is next week
but i'm sure uh crumblies might work
their way on that list uh possibly
they're still boneheads um it's still
part of that week i guess and we didn't
have them on last week so maybe they'll
work their way on but if you guys have a
suggestion of who you want to be
bonehead of the week visit bonehead of
the week.com or go to at tony michael
tonymichael's pod the twitter account or
you can just hit me or gabe up uh on our
twitter accounts i'm at the tony
michaels gabe yours
i am gabe sanchez so just hit us up on
the tweety tweets and that's and and
we'll we'll get this out hopefully we'll
have
our bonehead pull-up tomorrow uh we'll
definitely have it out for the podcast
on wednesdays don't forget to join us on
the podcast wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern right here
on youtube twitter twitch gabe we had a
great interview with heidi kuda uh that
we're gonna have on the podcast this
week it is fantastic um she talked about
queueing on uh i i really
i learned a lot but um it was actually
it was actually refreshing to hear
an investigative journalist like break
it down and use the word [ __ ] and say
this is a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
actually it was
it made me feel better about
feeling the way i do about like q anon
and how it's not just some [ __ ] crazy
cult like they really are trying to take
power
yeah
so join us join us wednesday for that
interview um and uh again go vote for
bonehead of the week and thanks for
joining us anything else you got gabe at
the end here
no
no just don't be a bonehead don't don't
be a [ __ ] bonehead and uh before we
go [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
[Music]
[Applause]